Таку картину цієї зими нерідко можна було побачити в Києві.
Українська столиця та інші міста поринали у темряву
після масованих обстрілів Росією енергооб'єктів.
Однак до квітня Україна досягла таких помітних успіхів
у відновленні інфраструктури, що вперше за пів року
починає експортувати електроенергію в інші країни.
Вже майже два місяці енергосистема працює без обмежень споживачів.
Українські енергетики вдалися до низки нестандартних методів,
кажуть у міністерстві. Завдяки цьому пошкодження вдалося
відновити набагато швидше.
Усіх секретів не розкривають.
Але один з них - коли перед обстрілом працівники енергосистеми
розвантажували потенційне місце удару і завдяки цьому
завдавалося менше збитків системі в цілому.
Крім того, українські енергетики нерідко ризикували життям,
аби швидше відремонтувати пошкоджені лінії та підстанції.
А нестачу потужностей, що виникла після окупації Запорізької АЕС,
вдалося компенсувати за рахунок завершення ремонту
Рівненської атомної електростанції.
На думку більшості експертів з питань енергетики,
рішення про експорт українського струму виправдане.
Я не впевнена, що ми зможемо вийти на повну потужність
як країна-експортер цього року через війну, через процес відновлення.
Але в будь-якому випадку я вважаю, що це добра ініціатива,
яку Європа має підтримати, знову ж таки, бо в майбутньому,
я думаю, ми зможемо забезпечити Європу більшою кількістю
електроенергії та енергетичною безпекою для тих
європейських країн, яким все ще потрібно більше електроенергії.
За оцінками експертів, нині в Україні справді виробляється
достатньо електроенергії. Споживання струму
після російського вторгнення зменшилося на 30 відсотків.
По-перше, припинили роботу великі підприємства-споживачі струму.
Зокрема, зруйновані комбінати в Маріуполі.
По-друге, мільйони українців виїхали за кордон.
Тож, нині Україна виробляє більше струму, ніж споживає.
Водночас експерти зазначають, що період експорту української
електрики буде короткостроковим і не зможе тривати цілий рік.
По-перше, нам потрібно відновити інфраструктуру.
По-друге, все ще триває війна, тому Росія все ще завдаватиме збитків.
І по-третє, ми повинні підготуватися до наступної зими.
Крім того, будуть й інші процеси, зокрема атомним електростанціям
потрібно буде виконувати деякі роботи з технічного обслуговування.
Тож якщо в України є можливість не просто брати гроші,
а й заробляти гроші - це непогана опція.
Пережити важку зиму Україні допомогли також
європейські партнери. Так, синхронізація з європейською
мережею допомогла українській енергосистемі залишатися
стабільною та уникнути великих системних аварій.
Не варто забувати і про поліпшення роботи української системи ППО:
більшість ракет та дронів вдається збивати.
Енергооб'єкти з кожним місяцем дедалі надійніше захищені.
Військові експерти констатують поразку стратегії Кремля:
ані знищити енергосистему, ані зламати волю українців
до боротьби Росії не вдалося.
То була стратегічна повітряна кампанія.
Мета ударів по інфраструктурі полягала в тому,
щоб підірвати волю українського народу до боротьби.
Очевидно, якщо вам взимку холодно, то ви замерзнете.
Зими підривають моральний дух. Але Росії цього не вдалося зробити.
Майже всі спостерігачі та експерти передбачали,
що цей план провалиться. Адже дуже важко знищити державну
інфраструктуру електропостачання без достовірної інформації
та дуже точного потрапляння в ціль.
Але й українці показали себе надзвичайно стійкими.
Їм вдалося легко полагодити пошкодження.
Тож з боку Росії це була марна трата боєприпасів.
І оскільки ми вступаємо в літню пору, проблема холодних
і темних ночей більше не актуальна.
Російські обстріли пошкодили понад 50 відсотків
енергетичної інфраструктури України. На її відновлення,
за найскромнішими оцінками програми розвитку ООН,
потрібен мільярд доларів.
Тим часом українські енергетики готуються до нових обстрілів
та наступної зими. Завдання номер один - захистити
найважливіші об'єкти. Очікується, що частину їх розміщуватимуть
під землею, що зробить їх недосяжними для російських ракет.
У Києві сподіваються, що експорт української електроенергії
допоможе Європі позбутися залежності від російського газу.
А Україні - накопичити кошти на підготовку
до опалювального сезону.